《红楼》第五世回,一场大学将落大观园,原内伤血最好的所在便是鲁雪安。于是中文今才就把试射活动安排在此处。曹雪芹起名为鲁雪广征连极景师。在这次连试游戏里,夹宝玉落地,大嫂子李湾为惩罚他,就令宝玉去龙翠安找妙玉,所要一两只红梅插平细少。
就在李湾安排任务的过程中,他非常自然地表达了对妙玉的不满。他说,我才看见龙翠安的红梅有趣,我要折抑之来插平,可也妙玉为人,我不理他。这句话如果出自他人之口,反倒没有细品的价值,可从李湾口中说出来,就格外引人注意。
李湾的人设是典型的老好人,对下人阶层向来是多恩少罚,被下人称为大菩萨。就因为这种性格,王夫任不敢把家务放心交给他。
圆入第五十五回,缝解生病,李湾临时管家,底下人听说李湾掌权一个个心中暗洗,觉得李湾好说话,工作也容易糖色。
李湾的性格和他寡妇的身份,注定了他不爱惹事。总管红楼全书,我们也几乎看不到,李湾对他人表示不满。
除了第四十五回所要设废,李湾与缝解玩笑焦风的几句,再无塌立可寻。
第五十回,李湾直接正面表示对妙欲的不喜,真可未是开天屁地投一走。
更值得对比的是他人对妙欲的态度。第四十一回,龙岁安品茶。
妙欲炒缝待遇连茶水都喝不出来,属于大俗人。
一向疯忙闭漏的待遇并没有与妙欲争论,操工写的是,
待遇知他天性怪癖不好多话,意不好多做,吃完茶,便约着宝差走了出来。
林待遇是有名的灵牙历尺,还被评价爱耍小性,可他能容忍妙欲的怪癖,反倒是肃有大菩萨美欲的李湾忍受不了。
乃至不顾以往多恩少罚的人社,直言对妙欲展开贬低性的评价,这是十分反常的。
除此之外,还有一处细节能证明,李湾对妙欲的验务具有某种独特性。
那就是第六十三回,甲宝欲生日。妙欲命人给一红院送去贺受信尖,
结果被压换们随手放在眼台底下,直到第二天才被发现。
原住是这样描述重人反应的。
宝欲指导,验台下是什么,一定又是哪位的样子忘记了收的。
秦文盟企业拿了出来,确实一张字铁,
地域宝欲看时原来是一张粉尖子,上面写着,看外人妙欲攻速遥口方臣,
宝欲看壁只跳了起来,忙问,这是谁接了来的,也不告诉,
习人秦文等见了这班,不知当时哪个要紧的人送来的铁子,忙一起问,
昨儿谁接下了一个铁子,似而忙飞跑进来,笑说,
昨儿妙欲并没亲来,只打发个妈妈送来,我就哥在那里,谁知一顿酒就忘了。
众人听了道,我当谁的这样大惊小怪,这也不值得。
大官员中人对妙欲的真实态度有此可见一般,
不仅接铁子的似而随手一放,过后就忘,
当因为宝欲十分惊慌,而跟着紧张的重庇,一直到对方是妙欲时,
大家的反应是立刻松下下来,而且觉得宝欲太大惊小怪,一点也不值得。
此处习人秦文的反应,跟上述龙翠安品尘时林代玉的反应一样,
他们都不会认真计较妙欲的所作所为,
可到了李丸这里,情况就发生了变化。
李丸和妙欲之间不像存在交集的样子,
妙欲没有得罪过李丸,李丸也没有跟妙欲起过冲突。
至少以红楼文本而言是这样的,
那么李丸为什么会验无妙欲?
又或者说,草血秦为什么要庞生之解,
给李丸安排这么一段戏?
对此有一个很好的分析视角,便是各位清拆的代表华。
草血秦给每位女子都安排了代表华,
比如,宝差是母单,代欲是符荣,叛春是姓华,乡云是海唐。
而李丸和妙欲的代表华则出现了巧妙的重点,
两人都是梅华,只不过李丸是老梅,妙欲是红梅。
李丸的老梅出自第63回一红夜宴,
中京餐完抽花签的游戏,
李丸抽中的花签上画着一只老梅,
写着双小寒资四字,
上有一句旧师写道,竹梨某舍自甘心。
妙欲的代表华是红梅,
是因为龙翠岸内中了好鲜红梅,
移到冬天变开的氛围腰柔,
加宝欲远远看见,都要注足欣赏。
李丸纵然不惜妙欲,
却也想折一两只龙翠岸的红梅来插屏。
李丸与妙欲,
以为竹梨某舍自甘心的老梅,
以为赢风怒放热人羡慕的红梅,
而者之间的差别细思可知。
世上没有无缘无故的爱恨,
而能彼此产生爱恨情绪的人往往具有同志性,
就好比一个人不会嫉妒八妃特比自己有钱,
可如果身边某位朋友过上了财务自由的生活,
就足以引起当时人羡慕可望甚至嫉妒的情绪。
正如欧利捐大官红楼所分析的内班,
由于孤玄于山外妙欲不与其他人发生互动,
也就淡化了大部分的负面情绪,
但唯独李丸这个童类无法事而不见。
这朵红梅价价于李丸依然竹梨某舍自甘心的白梅同志相识,
因此,平常随和荣众如菩萨般温婉承纵的李丸,
才会义反常态的严历刺之为为人可验,
而对他相应不敌。
我们对比李丸和妙欲的童志化特征会发现许多有意思的地方,
比如李丸所居道乡村,
村前清山鞋祖,
妙欲所居龙催安,安前山平衡根,
都在象征的两人或手寡或出家的优居处境,
与正常少女少父生活所隔举。此外,
道乡村仲然习近繁华,
竟显古谱农装特色,
可村子周围却开着如喷火征侠一般的数百竹红性,
前人学者多将此意象象征化,
认为这些红性象征李丸内心的青春向往,
但李丸的这些向往,
却以红梅的形式开进了妙欲的龙催安,
同志之间的心理矛盾由此产生。
妙欲虽是尼姑,
貌似受到和李丸一样的礼归限制,
但由于妙欲个人性情史然,
她的日子并没有过的向李丸纳班搞抹死灰。
她甚至可以主动给义性写性尖嚇售,
并于地76回月下连诗,
主动邀请待遇乡云来龙催安彻夜长流,
这些都是李丸不敢去做的。
为了规闭闲言碎语,
李丸日常连先宴的衣裳都不敢穿,
只粉打扮也都以素敬为主。
在这种情况下,
同志对比的心理就会悄然产生,
老梅欲上红梅,
一种不平衡感冲持在李丸心里,
化为属不清道不明的反感。
第五十回,保育起红梅,
相众龙催安红梅的人恰恰是李丸,
业务龙催安主人的也是李丸,
其中优异,留于诸君自行上玩。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,
我们下个视频再会。